before you could see us renovating this
old rune the whole thing is not straight
at all no wall is 90 degree in here and
they're just built very sketchy so we
build a wooden frame inside that will
carry the load of the roof
we've also built back the broken top and
now the wood and the bricks are
connected to each other
so now we actually have one solid
structure to continue with now that the
room walls are connected again we can
finally cut our last hole right there
we didn't do this before because we were
a bit skeptical if the wall would
actually hold it
and we'll use the bricks we get to close
the old entrance right there
so in this video we're going to make a
cut patch back a wall and build a window
frame and maktine and adrian are going
to make it
[Music]
so first step we are going to cut the
bricks open the window
we are not really sure about this so we
have this old
concrete uh
piece but we are not sure if it's gonna
really hold the full
wall so we are going to add a metal
lentil here
for that we also have martin he's a
nestor from the netherlands to help us
hi
my name is martijn
i'm a maker
and i just had my birthday here and i
turned 33
in my last job i was an engineer for a
company that makes cardboard houses
and now i'm at project camp to help make
the sketchy ruin less sketchy
besides making things i like to make
music
and i love dancing
someday i would like to live in a
community with my girlfriend let's see
what the future brings
first cut
[Music]
[Music]
do
[Music]
uh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
we have cut this size because then we
can
straight away put it in the door
would fit exactly the same thing
so less work let's clean the tires more
reducing
the wall was still stuck and we had to
do some more cutting
[Music]
wow i put the dirt on
[Music]
so we've finished the first half of the
hole for the window
and before i continue
i'm going to make sure
that all what's left here is not going
to follow my hat
i'm going to put a metal support in this
corner
[Music]
all the cuts in the wall have been made
and now it's time to take out the last
bit of wall
[Music]
cat is ready we are still alive and look
at the view
so next step we place the metal lintel
on top we will introduce it in the wall
by making some cuts we fill the gap with
cement to make everything a bit more
sturdy
[Music]
[Music]
okay next step is to put the
steel lentil
in position
and get it up to the right height
[Music]
all right now we have the lintel in
place
we're gonna put cement over here
and in that corner to keep it in place
[Music]
so
[Music]
so on both sides we've now filled the
space between the lintel
and the bricks
it's already starting to dry a little
bit
and now there's going to be more filling
on the other side of the wall
[Music]
before you could see that we're filling
in the space
between the brick
and the metal lintel
but as you can see
these bricks are all hollow
probably not so strong
so we're gonna fill all the gaps
with some cement
to make it a bit more uh strong
[Music]
so we've been cutting the hole before
this used to be a door and we're going
to close it because we made a door in
the side
and we like to reuse stuff so we decided
to use the whole section and just put it
in place
after this is in place
i will use new bricks to fill in the top
which is left
[Music]
hmm
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
for the big hole we cut in the wall now
we are going to make a window frame
we got gifted some really nice insulated
glass panels by ronald
a guy a dutch guy that lives around here
thanks ronald for that
and around those glass panels we we're
going to make a wooden window frame
we ask some local woodworkers to give us
a jump start by
making some really nice straight timber
for us with a nice groove to put the
glass so
we've got eight windows
we're going first we're going to make an
outside frame
then in the middle we're gonna place
another vertical one
and then we have
three horizontals
to end up with eight windows
so here's the design for the window
frame
the window frame itself
is made up of a outside frame
and an inside frame
the glass panels sit in a groove that's
cut into the wooden beams and are held
in place by a glazing bar
today emma is going to help me let's
start cutting
that's me baby
[Music]
[Music]
first
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Music]
just tuning the window frame it's over
there
i'm pretty happy with it it's nice and
tight
there's not so much steady machinery and
flat surfaces so i'm pretty happy how it
turned out
this
three screws
so
it's like this i think
so we already put the window on
we are trying to solve a couple of
problems we have in this ruin one of
them is like that's not a single surface
that is leveled nothing is balanced
nothing is square
as you can see
here like this one wall is a bit like
this
then this was not square with this one
so we are gonna make a frame now
to be able to level
a bit all our new surfaces including the
window the window is already level we
need to put a bit higher in one side
than in the other one in order to
have it level and then when the window
is level also the water will flow in a
better way if we don't have the window
level the water will be stuck in some
places
so next step is to build the frame
around
fix it and continue with the job
[Music]
we have test fitted the window frame in
the in the hole fits pretty well
and i've gave it some sanding and i've
cleaned up the edges of the frame with a
router to make it all nice and smooth
now it's time to paint it we're going to
use a clear
coat varnish to keep the wood good for a
longer time
and besides that it's going to be
painted it's going to be under
overhang of the roof which will protect
the winter frame from rain and sun
which is going to make it last for a
longer time
[Music]
now that the window frame has been
painted in a nice clear varnish
you can still see the beautiful pine
wood
we are going to put the glass the glass
is going to sit in this wooden groove
and to make a nice and airtight
connection between the glass and the
wood we are going to put foam strips
in the wooden groove
when the glass is in place
we're going to secure it with a glazing
bar
and the glazing bar has this foam strips
as well
to secure the glass
and
it's a little bit off the edge so you
have a nice space for silicon to go and
make a watertight connection
[Music]
[Music]
around the winter winter frame
we're making a nice granite edge
to
close the bricks
and to finish it off nice
split it up
[Music]
it's hot
hot very hot
and a small hole i see really small hole
[Music]
granite is in place
all the way around
final cleaning
window is ready
granite is ready one two three
[Music]
yeah you can go more to my yeah
more
[Music]
[Music]
cool that was it window is in place view
is in place
glass is in place
walls are closed
and that was it for this week thank you
for watching if you want to know more
about this ruin you can go to the
research topic you can find the link
below
and see you next week